I'm Justin this is Danny we have some
gamespot breaking news for you it turns
out that microsoft is offering people
hundred dollars if they go to a
microsoft store you know dedicated
stores for Microsoft content trade in
your ps3 any kind of ps3 and towards the
purchase of an xbox one something like
this one right here yeah so if you take
that ps3 you will get a crisp one
hundred dollars towards an xbox one I
mean you're not just getting a hundred
dollars it's really have you sure you're
okay with that all right thank you very
much this is great you sure this is real
I wouldn't know what what what do you
think about that is that is that worth
it would you take your ps3 and you know
get a hundred dollars off a next-gen
console I always feel like the people
who did that who traded in their console
to get a new one and with folks who were
they couldn't afford it like yeah
whenever I where I worked in gamestop
for a number of years back in Ireland
I'm with the kids the people who were
trading in old consoles to get new ones
we're basically kids who had saved up
enough money and then at a certain stage
just kind of justified it to themselves
like I'm not so sure if because you're
not just trading in a console to think
about when you do need to trade in your
PlayStation 3 is he basically also trade
in the ability to play every single game
you've ever bought on us so and the
other weird angle and this is then
presumably what you're actually doing is
kind of changing sides as well in a way
like this I guess there's no like
backwards compatibility between any of
these consoles at all but that's it so
weird like why would you I I wouldn't
want to do this for an xbox 360 for a
ps4 either just because the library of
games that you have on your current gen
system is so big so much bigger so
there's so many more things you can play
I wouldn't recommend picking up a ps4
xbox one at this point if you if you're
still on the fence could this be some
sort of public relations tactic Justin
this might have stuff to be doing is it
just microsoft store you can't do it
it's only microsoft stores you can't go
into gamestop or someplace like that oh
of course gamestop does take trade-ins
yeah if you have a 500 gigabyte
playstation 3 you can get a hundred
dollars if it's not a 500 gig you're
probably gonna get it a little bit less
than that so i mean in that sense it's a
good deal if you're looking to get rid
of your ps3 but if you're just looking
to pick up a next-gen console and you
don't want to get rid of your current
this is not a great deal you probably
don't wanna do that this is it's just a
publicity stunt it's funny the other
thing as well as if you're going
into a microsoft store presumably all
you're going to be able to do is give me
the playstation they'll just like chuck
it at the back none your games you can
trade in at least if you went to a
gamestop and you were trading it in
probably not going to get as much unless
you want a 500 gig which I don't know
that they're not exactly all over the
place and then you at least there you
can trade in all your software as well
you can trade in your games if you want
to do that but don't do that because you
know in like a year's time you're gonna
have a week off where you just lost your
job or you know you just watched our or
you just you've known your friends wanna
hang out with you because you're a
terrible person I mean you want to play
all your games I don't know it always
happens eventually what do you think
Microsoft is gonna do with all these
ps3s they're collecting ps3 you got to
throw in a min I'm gonna take a
photograph they're gonna put it up on
Instagram or something like that and be
like look at all the people who trade it
in their PlayStation trees to play the
latest xbox one they can drop them in
Dover waiting for all the games to
command for that system ya know I don't
know it just seems like a like a closed
system I guess if you're gonna trade in
a console if you really think you're
done with it but right now as somebody
who owns next-gen consoles from launch
week and is still kind of waiting for
that second round of software to comment
actually just the fire like I'm still
playing my xbox 360 I'm still playing my
ps3 seems a little bit early to be going
you know full hog into next-gen mega
later this year maybe it'll be a good
time to get those next-gen consoles but
if you want more console specific news
xbox one ps4 ps3 xbox 360 be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot follow us on
twitter follow us on Facebook you know
how all that stuff works give me my
hundred dollars back no no no I'm get
out of here